go  are you doing very disturbing video to  be sure police officers forcibly  removing a woman from a Southwest flight  from Baltimore to LA that grabbed her  arms as you see and then held her by the  chest as they literally pushed her down  the aisle this happened last night  Southwest claims a woman said she had a  life-threatening pet allergy but she did  not have the paperwork needed to fly  airline policy says it may deny boarding  for that reason two animals were on the  plane Southwest has apologized and  promised to reach out to this woman  passenger now we have the CEO of Delta  on deck in the green room and that's the  way they do not do it it Delta Airlines  he's sitting there looking at that video  evolved it's very tough to look at that